hello everyone my name is Ryan Johnson
and I'm a data science advisor here at
posit and welcome to this month's
Enterprise Community Meetup where we'll
discuss another end-to-end data science
workflow using posit team
as a reminder this is a recurring event
on the last Wednesday of every single
month and its goal is to provide the
data science Community with an overview
of pause a team especially for those
that may be unfamiliar with our
professional tools or maybe for those
that are looking for a refresher or
hoping to explore new capabilities and
features within positive team
every month we'll cover a different
topic and we're going to highlight all
three tools from within positive we have
positive workbench posit connect and
posit package manager
during and after each presentation
members of the posit team will be in the
chat to address any questions you have
about our tools workflows licensing
questions and anything else you may be
curious about
so for this month's topic we're going to
take a deep dive into one of our newest
open source tools called quarto quarto
is a technical publishing system and in
many ways it's similar to our markdown
but there's no dependency on the r
programming language so if you are a
python observable or Julia developer you
can also create a quarter document
now if you're new to quarto you are
absolutely in the right place as we are
going to create a brand new quarto
document from scratch using the rstudio
IDE within posit workbench
we'll then show how Corto can be used in
combination with posit connect to fuel
some really extremely powerful workflows
now before we get started I just want to
quickly review positive and we'll start
right here at the top with your data
scientists and your data analysts who
will be creating insights using posit
workbench
and they can choose to write code in
either r or Python and they have a
variety of Ides to choose from including
our studio cheaper lab Jupiter notebooks
and vs code
now for the R Developers they may be
creating content such as shiny
applications pins are marked down or
plumber apis and for python developers
they may be creating content such as
flask or fast apis streamlit shiny Dash
applications pins jupyter notebooks
now once the content is created the
developers will need a way to easily
share that content with viewers and
that's where posit connect comes into
play
connect not only makes your content
shareable but it also gives your team
tight control over content access and
can also be used for job scheduling
which we're going to talk about today
finally we have posit package manager
which does exactly as this name implies
and that's to host organize and
distribute open source R and python
packages not only from the community but
also any internally developed R in
Python packages
now for today's workflow we're going to
use the rstudio IDE from within posit
workbench to extract and save some data
as a pin and then we'll create some
insights from that pin data using quarto
which will then publish to posit connect
and then run it on a schedule
so to get started let's first talk about
the data we'll be analyzing today
and I thought it might be interesting to
extract some r package download data
from within posit package manager
and we can do this via an experimental
API from within package manager which
can be used to gather lots of great
information including package download
metrics
so this is great for auditing purposes
or maybe you're just curious to know how
popular is a certain package from within
your instance of positive package
manager
for example here's some example data
down here of what can be gleaned from
the package manager API on the left hand
we can see the our package name in this
case ggplot2 and then the number of
downloads of this package on a specific
day
now this data is constantly updating as
people continue to download packages
from posit package manager so one of the
goals for today is to automate the data
extraction and visualization steps so
that our final reports will reflect the
latest and greatest data
and that brings us to quarto so for
today's demo we're going to create two
quarto documents one will be for
Gathering processing and then saving our
data this is often referred to as an ETL
or extract transform load workflow
the other quarto document will be to
generate a report with tables and plots
to visualize our results
but what exactly is Corto
well Corto first and foremost is an open
source tool so if you have a computer
and you have internet access you can
create a quarto document
it's perfect for scientific and
Technical publishing and can really be
thought as like a next generation of our
markdown or our way of bringing our
markdown to everyone
and since there's no dependency on the r
programming language you can create a
quarter document if you're an R
developer python Julia or observable
programmer
you can also create quarto documents in
whatever environment is most comfortable
for you including vs code our studio
which is where we'll be today Jupiter
lab or any text editor
and you can also create a variety of
content including articles reports
presentations websites blogs and books
in a variety of formats including HTML
PDF Microsoft Word ePub and lots more
so let's review our workflow for today
so we're going to draw in package
download data from posit package
managers API and we're going to pin that
data to posit Connect using quarto
we'll then show you how to schedule this
quarter document to run using posit
connect which will automatically update
the pinned data
finally we'll create a second quarter
document for visualizing our package
download metrics which will also publish
in schedule to run on posit connect
we'll also apply a custom theme to the
second quarter document to make it look
really nice
now for our data we are going to use
posit's public package manager here so I
click on this link
so this is a free hosted service that
provides standard mirrors of popular R
and python repositories including cran
bioconductor and Pi Pi
Additionally you can track repository
changes over time you can freeze
repositories to specific dates and
install packages as pre-compiled Linux
binaries
now this instance of package manager is
used by hundreds of data science teams
throughout the world and will serve as a
good proxy for understanding our package
download trends
so to get started let me come back here
to my slides
to get started we're going to show
everyone how to create a quarto document
from scratch using the rstudio IDE
so we're going to go into posit
workbench here and open up a new rstudio
session and then create an R Studio
project for our workflow
all right so we're going to be using our
demo environment here at posit so I'll
select posit workbench
you can see I already have an rstudio
session running but we're going to
create a brand new session for today's
workflow so I'll click new session
here I can choose my Ides and I'm going
to select rstudio for today
we can give it a custom name if we
wanted to now our demo environments in a
kubernetes cluster which allows me to
choose various cluster options I'll just
leave it as default today but if I did
have a more computationally intensive
job I could choose a larger instance
but we'll just leave it as default and
I'll hit start session
and we'll just give this a few seconds
to boot up
foreign
here we are with in our new R studio
session and in the top right corner you
can see project none so I'm not
currently within a project so let's go
ahead and change that I'll select this
option at the top click new project
now we have some options of where we
want to place this project it can be in
a new directory an existing directory or
pull in a project from Version Control
we'll select new directory for today
it's like new project
and I'll give this directory a name I'll
just say demo
test and I'll put one two three after it
and we'll hit create project
now anytime you open up a new project it
will open up a new rstudio session so
we'll just give this a few seconds to
boot up
all right so here we are within our new
rstudio project and you can see the name
of our project here in the top right
corner
and our first step will be to create a
blank quarto file now we can do this by
clicking this new blank file drop down
right here and we can select quarto doc
I'm going to give this name of this
quarter document ETL for our extract
transform and load a workflow here and
hit OK
all right so here we have a blank quarto
document on the left hand side of our
screen and our source panel
so next with the help of our visual
markdown editor so you can see I'm
currently on Source I'm going to click
on visual
so we're going to add our first
component to our quarto document and
that's going to be the yaml now yamls
are usually found at the very top of the
quarto documents and are used to provide
various metadata to our documents so
let's go ahead and add a yaml to this
blank quarter Doc and then we'll add a
title and an author so to add a yaml
I'll go to this insert drop down and all
the way towards the bottom you'll see
yaml block
all right yaml has these three dashes at
the top three dashes at the bottom put
my cursor right in between and I'll
start typing title
and we'll give this title I'll call it
ETL
we're going to add one more key value
pair here I'm going to say author
and I'll put my name
and that's it
now just for right now we haven't added
a whole lot but let's go ahead and
render this core to a document and by
default it'll use HTML so we can use
click on this render button
and we'll let quarto work its magic
all right so here's the current state of
our quarto document we have our title
and then the author nothing fancy
so next we're going to add some R code
and we do this by adding an R code chunk
or a cell to our document
and this can be found in the same kind
of insert drop down menu
so I'm going to click insert code cell
and we're going to add an R code chunk
or a code cell
now to save some time I'm actually going
to copy and paste some R code which I'll
explain here in a bit
so for right now I'm just going to copy
off screen here I'm going to paste into
this code chunk some functions to load a
few packages for our workflow for today
but again we'll explain all this code
here in a bit
so next I'm going to copy in some text
which provides the reader with some
background information regarding the ETL
process within this quarto doc
so again I'm also going to copy this off
screen and I'm going to paste it right
here into my quarto document and you can
see this nicely rendered markdown text
within this visual markdown editor
let's go ahead and render this document
and now see what it looks like
okay
all right so we still have our title
there's our author you can see some of
the code and its output right underneath
and then down here towards the bottom
you can see all that text that we added
and it's starting to look really nice so
let's close out of this
now I'm going to add some more code and
text and I'm going to explain this code
in text in a little bit so I'm just
going to go ahead and paste it all in
here
and so pretty much we have our final ETL
quarto document and we can now publish
it to posit connect so I'm going to go
ahead and start that process now since
some of the r code takes a little bit of
time to run and while it's publishing
we'll go back into that quarter document
and explain some of the code in the text
that we added so to publish this quarto
document
you'll see this little blue button at
the top of your screen this is our
publishing button so I'll click on this
we're going to choose posit connect
and we're going to publish this document
with the source code which is really
important for job scheduling
all right so we're only going to publish
the single etl.qmd file which is what
you see over here on the left hand side
we're going to publish it to our demo
environment of connect which we call
Colorado and we'll just leave the title
as ETL and I'll just go ahead and hit
publish
and once we do that down here in our
console there's going to be this deploy
tab that opens up and this is all
running behind the scenes essentially
what's happening is that it's capturing
my environment it's looking to see what
packages I use what versions of those
packages what our version what quarto
version it captures that sends it to
connect connect replicates my
environment and then deploys this
quarter document
so let's come back into this quarter
document and explain all the code and
the text that I added
so in this first code chunk right up
here we are just loading some R packages
for this analysis
and then in the text right here we're
essentially just you know adding some
information about what this ETL process
is doing
and essentially I'm creating two custom
functions which will query that posit
package manager API
so then we use those two functions in
this following code chunk that starts
right here and it's a pretty big one
these are the two functions that I
created
so once we create those two functions
basically what we're going to be doing
is using those two functions to gather
package download metrics for three
packages we have ggplot2 D ply R and
shiny
this first code chunk right here is
going to get the total downloads over
the last 30 days for each of those
packages it then combines it into a
single data frame or a table and then it
will print the results
and then in this last code It's Already
Done publishing we'll come back here
and this next code chunk right here
we're going to get similar data but
instead we're going to get the total
downloads per day over that same time
frame the same 30 days for ggplot2 dply
R shiny and then we're going to print
just the first 10 rows of that resolving
data frame
finally we take the package down the
results and we're going to pin them to
posit connect all right that's all done
right here in this code chunk
now for those that are new to the pins
package this is a very easy two-step
process we first register our pin board
which in this case is posit Connect
using the board connect function
and then we'll write the two data sets
as pins to posit Connect using the pin
write function and that's pretty much it
so here is the published quarto document
now on posit connect but I'd first like
to show you what the two pinned data
sets look like on the posit connect
server
so let me open up a new tab here
oh I'm going to duplicate this one
I'm going to come back to the content on
our connect instance and here are those
two pins that we just pinned deposit
connect so I'll click on this first one
and at the very top right you can see
the name of the PIN followed by a link
to download the data directly
next there is an R code snippet that
gives it users instructions for how to
read this pin into their workflows
and finally we can see a paginated
preview of the pinned data
all right now let's switch back over to
our posit or sorry our quarto document
that we just published to posit connect
now as a publisher I not only have
control over who has access to this
document but I could also schedule all
the code to run on a recurring schedule
now since the data we're working with
this package download data since it
updates daily let's set this set this
document to run every single morning at
7am
so to do this I'll first click on the
schedule tab right over here
and we'll select the box to schedule
output for default
so next you can choose your time zone
and then the start date and time now
we're going to set this to run every day
at 7am so let's move the time to 7 am
and we're going to choose daily which is
already selected alright so essentially
now this will run every single morning
at 7am
this way the pin data sets will remain
updated without any manual intervention
and you can essentially set it and
forget it
you'll also see two boxes down here at
the bottom so that first one means that
the report you see on your left will be
updated and republished every time the
document runs
and the second box right down here is to
send an email to users letting them know
the document was rerun
now we're going to create a second
quarto document right now and we're
actually going to demo this feature
alrighty so let's go ahead back into
posit workbench I'm going to close out
of this ETL script
and we're going to create another quarto
report or a quarter document
so
I'm going to close out of this and we'll
select new blank file
to a quart of a dock now I'm going to
call this document boring report
and hit OK
now I'm first going to create a yaml
just like we did before I'm going to add
a title and an author and again we'll
use the visual markdown Editor to help
us out here
so I'll go to insert scroll down to yaml
add a title
and I'll call this boring report
you'll see why it's boring here in a
second and then I'll have author and I'm
going to add my name
so next I'm going to copy in some code
to load a few R packages so let me first
go ahead and create a code chunk or code
cell
and then I'm going to add in some code
right here we're going to load in two
packages we have the pins package and
also the Tidy verse package
so after that we're going to add in a
little bit of text here which is just
kind of introducing all of our readers
to this report
so again I'm just copying and pasting
this off screen for the sake of time
all right and now I'm going to copy in
some more code here
and the first code chunk is basically
going to read in that pinned data so if
you remember when we looked at that pin
on posit connect it actually included
some R code Snippets to draw in those
pins into our workflows
so I'm going to go ahead and copy that
code
let me first actually give this a title
right here we're going to have with two
hashes I'll say package download metrics
add in a new code cell
and I'm going to paste in this code so
again we first register our pin board
just cases posit connect and then we're
going to read in those two pinned data
sets
now finally I'm going to add two code
chunks the first is going to print all
right that that first pin this one right
here
it's just going to print kind of the raw
data which is going to be a data frame
the second we're actually going to
create a plot using the ggplot2 package
and it'll look at the same download Over
the same data over the last 30-day
window so we can kind of visualize some
Trends in our package download metrics
so let me go ahead and grab that code
I'll first add a code chunk here
and again this first one is just going
to print the results or print that first
pin data set right there
and then I'm going to add another code
cell
and this is going to create a plot
again using the ggplot2 package
so let's go ahead and render this
quarter document to see what it
currently looks like and again this is
our boring report so we'll render this
and we'll give it a few seconds to run
all right so it's almost done
and here we go
so this is our final HTML boring report
you can see there is my name and then we
have our code and again if there's any
output from that code whether it be a
table a plot or just some text it'll
show up directly underneath that code
chunk
we have some of the text that we added
right here
all right and then we have our package
download metrics so this is where we
connected to our posit connect instance
and then read those two pins
this first code chunk all it does is
just print the first pin so you can see
those three packages and how many
downloads over the last 30 days
and then the second code chunk right
here it creates a plot this is a pretty
good looking plot all right we're
looking at trends of those three
packages over time which is along the
x-axis downloads along the y-axis
so this report
um you know we created it certainly gets
the job done but it's kind of bland and
certainly could use some sprucing up
also it could be really nice to add some
custom theming to our quarto document
that includes our company's colors and
logo
and you know we want to create something
that would really impress our leadership
so to get started I'm actually going to
come back here to posit workbench
and I'm going to download a custom posit
format that I created and is now hosted
on GitHub and that's what you're seeing
right here I did this just a few days
ago and this is a simple posit quarto
theme
now if you're ever curious about how to
create your own theme or template the
quarto website is has some great
documentation for this so here we have
for custom HTML themes and also for
creating customized templates for your
workflows for your team
so coming back to this custom theme I
created on GitHub I included some
instructions for how to use it so I'm
going to copy this code I'm going to
come back and deposit workbench I'm
going to open up my console down here
and within the terminal tab right here
I'm going to paste that command and
we'll hit enter
and we'll basically just follow the
instructions the first thing to ask do
you trust the authors well the author is
me so I certainly trust myself I'll say
y for yes and then we can give this
template it's going to be into a
directory so we can give that directory
a name I'll just say posit theme and hit
enter
and now if you look in our files
directory right down here you'll see
this positive theme folder
now within this new directory let me
click into it
it includes a template quarto document
which is shown right here it is posit
theme.qmd
and it also includes an example HTML
output file which is right here so if I
click on this and view in my web browser
here is what that quarto theme looks
like and it looks pretty nice you see we
have a nice logo at the top of the
screen all the headers and the text and
the links basically reflect posit colors
that we use for our company
and so this is kind of the template we
want to use for our report
so let's go ahead and open up this posit
theme template right here
and I'm currently viewing it in the
source viewer so I'm going to actually
delete pretty much all the placeholder
text right here
I'm going to come into my boring report
I'm going to click on source and I'm
just going to copy everything from our
boring report copy and paste it into our
nice report and we'll select the visual
markdown editor again
all right let's just go ahead and render
this posit theme this uh custom theme
report and see what it looks like
all right so here is now our theme
report so again you can see the logo the
headers look really great
and it's starting to look pretty good
all right the text looks good got a lot
of code we got a lot kind of a basic
kind of noise here like do we really
need to see this you know we can
probably really Spruce this up a little
bit and also the plot while it's still a
good looking plot you know the colors
are the generic ggplot2 colors maybe we
can have those reflect posit colors
so to improve the look of this quarter
document I'm going to close out of this
let's first add a custom posit color
palette and we're going to do this using
a package called R color Brewer so let
me go ahead and first and load that into
my environment
I'll make my screen a little bit bigger
here
so using a library function we'll run R
color
Brewer
and we're going to add that palette
directly underneath here so I'm going to
copy this off screen
come back here into this R code and I'm
going to paste it right in there so this
is all the code we need to create a
posit themed color palette which we're
going to use for our plot and also for
our table
so let's come back down here
we have our pinned
read our code chunk and then we had this
code chunk which as we know just printed
the raw data frame it did not look very
good
so let's convert this printed text
output and we're going to basically make
it a table and I'm going to add some
posit themed coloring to do this we're
going to use a package called GT so
let's first load that package at the
very top and I'm going to copy in the
code to create a GT table and we'll run
it here so you can see the output so
I'll First Run library to load the GT
package I'm going to run this code chunk
here within posit workbench
all right we'll come back down here
let's read in those pinned data sets
and now I'm going to come in right here
I'm going to replace this text with a GT
table and if you've never used GT tables
before they are so much fun create
really nice tables so I'm going to paste
in all the code and let's run it
and here is now what our table looks
like which looks a whole lot nicer than
just that raw data frame text
finally let's change the look of our
ggplot to include our posit colors and
we'll also tweak The Look by adding a
minimal theme and customizing the title
and the labels as well
so I'm just going to copy this code off
screen come back here I'm going to
replace this text
with some more ggplot text and let me
run this so you can see it here within
quarto
and there we go so you see some nice
posit colored lines right here
and this is already starting to look a
lot better let's go ahead and render it
and see the current
state of this quarto document
foreign
Ty look pretty good still have our posit
theme scroll down here to our table so
that looks really nice and then we'll
scroll down here to our plot and that
also looks really nice
now it looks pretty good but since most
of our viewers of our document won't be
really interested in the code let's go
ahead and hide I know all the code and
any kind of messages from the final HTML
output so let me close out of this I'm
going to scroll back up to my quarter
document the very top in our yaml
so we're going to add a few things here
I'm going to add an execute key and
we're going to apply some code chunk
options which will basically apply to
all the code chunks in the document so I
first want to hide all the code from the
output by setting Echo to false
and then we'll hide any warning messages
by setting warning to false as well
all right I think this is going to look
pretty good let's go ahead I'll save it
render this final quarto document
and here we go so now we're not seeing
any of the code we're only seeing the
output the tables and the plots all
right see if we can see our nice table
right here which again is looking at
those three packages and total downloads
over the past 30 days and here we look
at those same three packages every
single day they're download metrics for
the past 30 days
all right this is a great report
so now that we have this final report
let's go ahead and publish it to posit
connect just like we did before
so I'll click on that blue publish
button here within workbench
select connect we're going to publish
this document with the source code since
we want to schedule it to run just like
before
we're going to publish it to our same
demo environment Colorado here's all the
files and some of the dependencies
needed for that custom theme and we'll
leave the title as a posit theme as well
so again anytime you publish from within
your studio IDE use this blue button the
next thing that will happen will be this
deploy tab and again essentially what's
happening is our studio is capturing my
environment and you can see some of the
logs here it'll print out you know
certain packages that are needed for
this quarto document and the associated
versions
so we'll just give this a few seconds to
run
and then we'll come back together once
it's all published
I'll give us a few more seconds
it's now rendering the quarto document
it's the last step
it's running all those various code
chunks there's the output file
and
there we go
and now here is our final report now
hosted published to posit connect
and so once it's here again the main
advantage is you have tight control as a
publisher over who has access to this
document so for example if I wanted to
define specific users or groups I can
Define them right here so if I wanted to
share this with Rachel for example I
most certainly could and now we would be
the only two people here at posit that
would have access to this quarto
document this report
I could alternatively select this middle
option right here and basically have all
users login required so as long as you
can log into posit connect you can view
this content that would essentially open
this up to all positive employees
so next we'll want to make sure that
this quarter document is scheduled to
rerun so that it reads in that new
pinned data set which again is being
updated every single day at 7am and it
Updates this report so that these
numbers reflect you know those new
package data every single day
so let's set it to rerun basically daily
at let's just say noon every single day
and we'll go through the same workflow
I'll click on schedule
output for default choose your time zone
and I'm going to select noon
and we'll run this every single day
now this time we're also going to send
an emailed notification to our teammates
to let them know the report was run so
to do this we select this box right here
at the bottom
and we can add our either collaborators
or viewers which we assigned previously
so that was Rachel or I can come in here
and I can add Rachel directly for
example
and so once we do this
Rachel basically every single day around
noon she'll get an email with a direct
link to this report so that she can view
the latest package download metrics and
if we switch back to my slides here I
actually have an example of what one of
those emailed reports looks like
so you can see here that it's sent
directly by posit connect with me as the
sender and it links to the latest
versions of the report
the subject line you see up here at the
top is also customizable and it also
attaches an HTML version of the quarto
report directly to this email
all right and so with that we have come
to the end of our workflow for today
now I hope everyone found this month's
demo helpful and we'd love to chat more
about positive quarto pins job
scheduling or anything else so feel free
to stick around and we'll have a few
positive folks available to answer any
questions you have thanks everyone for
joining and I hope I look forward to
seeing everyone again next month
thank you so much for the great demo
Ryan and thank you everybody for joining
us today I see there's already been a
few great questions in the chat we are
going to do things a little bit
differently than the last two months
where we're gonna try and answer
questions live instead of just in the
chat as well so as a reminder there's
also a slido link open for anonymous
questions and so that's at p o s dot i t
slash demo Dash questions and I'll put
that here in the chat in another second
here too
um but we're going to send you over to
another platform for the Q a and it
should automatically send you there from
YouTube right now but thank you again
and have a great rest of the day we'll
see you over in the Q a